takes 30 seconds because of the latency
hey there's my logo above my head
nobody has been received by cmr
ah
hello i'm chris i'm very loud
turn me down
and you're muted i'm not muted anymore
that works
hello
hello hello hello
there we go
hello hello okay i think we're good i
think we're good i think we're gonna
think we're good
okay we're hanging out guys
what's up what's with all you know
andrew garfield going on right now
this is what i say welcome back another
week
another live stream hanging out with
everybody
oh my god i like the video it sounds
like uh we can hear now
is the audio good is one of us more
than the other
cosmic corner goes woof just like andrew
the werewolf
mcu spidey now i'm very quiet good
just kidding i'll get you up i'll keep
it right there you're right there
all right guys this is uh
this has been pretty funny it to me
[Laughter]
it's been so funny to me because
one okay and this is no offense to
anybody
but one uh what's hilarious to me is
when
videos like these come out where actors
are denying
you know being in movies for the mcu and
stuff like that after you know like
several
different media outlets like reputable
media outlets have like
reported them to be in it and it's just
kind of like they do an interview that's
like
hey i'm not in it
and everyone's like it's confirmed he's
not in it i'm like what do you think
he's gonna say
you think he's gonna say yeah a minute
hey thanks jake heads for that super
chat yeah he was so that's what we're
about to talk about right
and i hope you're well as well um
but like i mean jeez like
he can't say yes he can't say yeah i
mean
spider-man no way home he can't say that
i mean there's literally just no no way
any of them right
all the way down to you know the highest
of all the actors robert downey jr none
of them have a license to
reveal what's going on no they get so
much trouble so it's like oh let me go
in an interview hey andrew are you in
spider-man yeah dude i'm totally in
spider-man
like that's just not an option there's
zero
possibility where where that exists
where that scenario exists anywhere
there's zero chance that he could ever
say yes i am in spider-man no way home
yes
the multiverse exists like there's zero
chance anywhere that that could happen
but the biggest thing that we want to
talk about today in this live stream
is the fact that he had like this story
right the werewolf story like the mafia
story
um i'm not the werewolf i'm not the
effing werewolf like
right right right and i just the way he
jumped at it in the very first video
when when he was like oh i don't want to
spoil anything he like genuinely let me
stop you right there
let me stop you right there like the way
the way he jumped at josh
and the happy side confused podcast i'm
like dang he's
really like just jumping on this thing
right he was ready to say because he
knew what he was gonna say
right yeah yeah jake hedge thanks for
another super chat
his scenario about mafia was basically
him saying yes he said if you're the
mafia then you can't say
you are and was pointing out himself
that's kind of funny that's like kind of
that's kind of like a true very good
story that sounds like a very marvelous
thing to do right right just tell them
you're you know just tell them you're
not the werewolf
but that's you're 100 right isn't that
the goal of werewolves that's the whole
point and mafia
is to convince people that you're not
the werewolf
right that's the whole point is to
convince people you're not
but the way he was so defensive at first
and just his overall reaction
was enough for me to go okay i'm kind of
convinced
like 100 now that you're in the movie
especially because he never
said no no and then even in
in that same one that same interview and
when he like can i get a definite
no then and he he just like didn't i
just say no
didn't i just say no like josh was like
okay yeah you did and i'm like no
i want to go right just like say no
right now yes or no right are you in
spiderman i'm not a werewolf man
like he's never and people have asked
him like straight up and he has never
said no no that's true never
one time as he said no he is he's just
danced around it but so we have that one
and then we have the other interview and
then he
he he talks the same thing right i think
he's on
entertainment weekly or something like
that yeah something like that that might
not be it but
something similar where they asked him
the same question
and he's like i feel like i'm playing
werewolf like i'm not the werewolf guys
right it's just kind of like okay like
let me tell you this if he's playing
among us i'd vote him out right now i
would vote him out in among those so
hard i would vote him out
so quick dang it now i wish i uh changed
no i wish we had that thought before
this video so i could have put the
thumbnail as like
kicking out andrew garfield and among us
and i would have put our
uh us as the two other guys
um and the other thing to know and you
know we'll talk about paul rudd
and tatiana when when they were asked
hawkeye jimmy renner everybody like they
were very
elegant right they were like like paul
reads the video he's just so
casual i don't know what you're talking
about man like i don't have an answer
and walks away
and you're like what's that garfield is
just so
like zeroed in on it
and so aggressive and stuttering you
know he's an actor and he's sitting
there like
like um like um like um um like well
because
according to skyler schuler at the
disney setter
um he reported yesterday two days ago
maybe that
that they're like really pressuring them
to be quiet
and it's like it's the worst kept secret
in hollywood
it's the worst kept secret like
you're trying to hide something that
everybody knows
and the only reason that they are
straight up sticking to it
is so there is that shred of doubt now
i'm going to say if we're wrong i mean
holy crap kudos to
i mean wouldn't marvel say guys really
you would think this
you know right like to me
how long how long did they keep up this
giraffe all right let's assume it's the
spider-verse super movie we're getting
every spider-verse character ever
existent
do they keep this a secret until the
movie actually goes live
yeah or do we get a trailer and they're
like all right guys get excited
where does it just like nothing until
the movie starts i don't think
we i don't think we see them i i
i think it's going to be like avengers
end game
you didn't see cap wield the hammer in
the trailers until the movie was out
and then like a few days after it's
average a symbol and it's just kind of
right
right right you know what i mean i mean
it's a big secret
yeah hey uh kwame i or quam i'm sorry if
i pronounce it wrong thanks for that
super chat
he says i listened to the whole podcast
and andrew was so calm and relaxed until
that question was asked
he put on a whole performance ha ha yeah
no
same here i watched i watched a lot of
it uh peter parker
or the moment when he said an interview
with the guy when he literally said pee
pee poo poo
thanks for that super chat uh it's just
funny
to me how rehearsed it was it was
literally like to me i felt like it was
probably something like kevin feige
was like just tell him this right any
time in an interview
but it's so weird to me that he won't
say no
what is this like a world compass or
something like that right you can say
no you know what i mean right so and
then you think about
i'm sorry just want to build off of your
point right now like what you're saying
about like
this is what kevin feige told me to say
we've seen the exact same thing from tom
holland too where they've said this
exact same line almost verbatim you know
like it's not happening but it would be
really cool idea like they've both
actually said that now
yeah hey rory jacks up in the chat
what's up guys
andrew garfield is 99.999999999 i feel
like i'm
like german nine nine nine
i'm gonna say that's like 13 nines yeah
um
but it's just so it's just so funny
you'll save your
zero one 0.10001 doubt okay so well
that's what i'm talking about right now
and i'm
gonna assume it's greg if it's john let
me know or both you
um i
i if if he's not in the movie if it's
not a spider-verse movie
kudos to freaking andrew garfield
for not saying no because
it's like he him not saying no
is us going hey he's not saying no and
they know that right
does that make sense am i am i losing
people here well for sure
no i i think just the performance right
the whole thing you line it up just off
of what andrew garfield has
had said in these three interviews not
including all the other evidence and
things we know
just based off of the repetition of what
he said how excitable he gets when he's
talking about it and the fact that he
really won't give us
a definite no it's just like
you're not that good at this hey greg
oh hey i hope we can be entertaining on
the road
um i'm i'm oh it is greg what's up i'm
just saying
it's incredibly smart if he's not in the
movie for him to not say no
because if you if you never show
anything
relating to i i shouldn't say spider
verse because i think they'll show like
doc ock and
um right right electric how confirmed
are those two characters oh
are they all yeah from jamie foxx
confirmed it he put a picture on
instagram okay
and then now for molina straight up was
talking about it in an interview
we have a confirmed villain from each of
these other universes right
right in this movie you know tom
holland's been back and forth with what
he's been saying you know originally he
was like oh i've heard nothing
and then originally he was like no it's
a definite no and now you've got andrew
garfield doing the same thing
toby mcguire is a genius he's just
hiding toby mcguire has done
an excellent i want nothing to do with
any of it speaking of peter parker
thanks again for that super chat you are
the only peter parker
of this universe no i i appreciate that
subject
well it's funny because like we've seen
toby two times
and and and each time he's came out it's
like
i dissect i dissolve i'll be the first
to admit like i'll dissect
everything that's happening so the first
time we saw him he's looking like not in
bad shape but he's like
not well groomed he's got like a beard
uh not movie ready
not movie ready a little out of shape
tiny bit of [ __ ] right and the next time
we see him
it's like okay super clean cut looking
really good looking in better shape just
like okay
you you just filmed spider-man didn't
you because the only other movie
that he could be in is like babylon i
think it's the name of it
but that's he's not confirmed to be in
that movie that's not a confirmation
he's rumored
he was rumored to be eyed for that movie
so that's not even like a
like rumored that the studio wants him
to play the part like that is nowhere
near
like that's nowhere near he has this
next movie so it's like okay
we're going to say he has no movies
coming up um right
you know he has no movies coming up and
what is he doing going to get like
fitted for costumes
like that like well i mean miraculously
disappears
throughout the entire filming well
that's the that's the crazy part too
it's like we see him
for the fitting he disappears during the
whole filming filming ends and then we
see him again
in better shape looking better shaved
yeah right
right so but to get to the main point of
this live stream
was andrew garfield said all this stuff
but then he went back
on it yep right he
he came out another one and he said
never say never
right he he kind of did he dropped the
werewolf story completely
when that happened let's listen to i'll
play right now i'll play it right now
i'll play it right
i have to bring this up
oh and of course i like i forgot where i
had it
uh where'd it go i emailed you it you
did email me it
here it is but i gotta download it
download bear with me guys let's play
though this one's alright oh no yeah
it's okay here we go i got it i got it
you got it yeah go for it all right guys
so
here's what here's what he said
i i've of course you know i've heard all
the rumors of everything
and to be frank i think it's a really
cool idea
but like um but like uh as a fan just as
a pure fan
to have like yeah it's a really cool
idea
um but yeah as i as i've said previously
it's not something that i
you know i don't god i hate being given
the responsibility of disappointing
people
um but yeah no it's not something that
i'm uh
that i've been um asked about or
anything like that but you know never
say never
never say never like again
what just give me a straight answer bro
like
what like i don't but but he changed his
demeanor completely
right it's the stuttering for me you
know
well so when he said that one part was
like that i don't want to be the
one of like disappointment and i'm
sitting there kind of just like
you are you're trying to figure out what
to say without
saying something you're not supposed to
say uh and hold on real fast
uh moses's world tom holland has
uncharted also
yeah tom i mean tom has other movies
but toby maguire is the one that we're
like he has nothing after this right so
what could he be getting a costume
fitting for right so exactly right
tom tom holland uh it's like really
weird it's like the only one i'm not
concerned about right now because i mean
he's the main star of the movie so it's
like you know
i uh i'm i i'm really
looking into all the details now
of like andrew garfield's life and tommy
mcguire's life
and it's like anywhere they're spotted
you know but here's the other thing
andrew garfield stunt double has been
pretty open
about oh yeah being on the set
of no way home and he hasn't straight up
said like oh i'm filming no way home
today
but you know like the pictures that he
posts are in the
studio right and then he tags tom hall
and stunt double and at one point in
time he tagged toby mcguire's stunt
double
yeah so it's like it's just tom tom and
then tom
tom doesn't need that many stunt doubles
right i mean the only reason there would
be so many on set is if there were
multiple spider myths
right and then you know you add on top
of that
what was it the november or december
that what was that latin american
trailer that came out
they're like get ready for the spider
verse gosh
like that wasn't us that wasn't us no
they straight
so i posted that trailer and they
copyrighted me for it
did they they actually gave me a
copyright strike
that's a big deal like that's a huge
deal
like i put i posted the trailer and it
got like 300 000 views or something like
that
and then like sony brazil or something
yeah copy struck it and i'm just like
okay
so spider-man far from home comes out
right
and they drop a freaking uh tv spot
every other day
for like a month and i i do like 20
videos straight up just posting these
never say a word
don't even copyright any of it right and
then i do this trailer
that happened to be about the spider
verse and i it gets a strike
right right right right uh garrett
gutierrez thank you for that super chat
if toby and andrew are to know at home
i'll donate my infinity gallon issue
number one signed by stan himself
so you can use in a giveaway i i don't
think i i will win the giveaway
i think i would keep that that's a
that's a that's a bold statement right
there that's a bull bet but hey thanks
for that super chat
i think quite frankly though it is that
level of confidence with fans across the
board you know not just the youtubers
crying wolf
it is almost all the fans at this point
have this level of expectation for this
movie
elliot rosters in the chat elliot
roster's in the chat
he says what's up uh super mario
simones thank you very much i appreciate
that
yeah so who else that we haven't
mentioned somebody in the chat mentioned
that miles morales hasn't talked about
you know
and that's because there isn't a live
action actor for us to to stalk to find
out if he's in it
but do you think we'll get a miles
morales do you think we'll get a
spider-man 2099
like do you think these are options or
do you think it's gonna be the main
three uh
i i think it should be the main three
i i don't think like i think
2099 and miles morales are great
it would be cool if they set them up
which i think if you have
the spider-verse it does set them up
okay
but i would like miles to be a part
of the main mcu oh a hundred percent i
would
love to see him and he and he is
because of childish gambino's prowler
yeah
he already mentioned his nephew right so
he is
um so you don't want him to have
multiverse character you want him to be
a main line i want him to remain himself
timeline the sacred timeline as we're
learning from loki the sacred time yeah
yeah gameboy 98 thanks for that super
chat i bet he's lying
so that no way home doesn't get spoiled
so when it comes out people would freak
out
once it moves out yeah absolutely and um
you know thanks again for that super
chat but like that takes me back to like
the trailers do i think
they're gonna be in it definitely not
the teaser
but you know if they
got if they put them and they tease them
in the main trailer
i think it just it deflates
the situation no i think it makes
everybody go to the theater
that's true i personally would love to
go into this not knowing
i would love to go to the theater
because you know what everybody's gonna
go watch it's a spider-man movie right
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
so scared going into
the movie with if they don't mention it
or anything at all
because everyone's gonna be like you
were and it's not just me it's everybody
on the internet
oh there isn't there isn't a social
media person out there that isn't saying
that he's in it
yeah there's not a youtuber charles
murphy even today almost every day
swears tooth and nail it's gonna happen
you know it's like everybody's saying
it's gonna happen i mean charles murphy
daniel rbk
scott schuler like uh all the people who
tend to know things and uh i've asked my
disney contact and i get a no comment
right that doesn't that doesn't mean yes
or no
right that's the true like no i like i
can't comment on that is what he told me
right it's like
uh and i was like of course you can't i
just had to ask
uh retro man think about super chat
cosmic wonders it's honored to see you
oh thank you
by the way today's 10 year anniversary
of spider-man 4 that should have been
released hopefully it comes back yeah
it's not a bummer
there have been rumors that you know
they might make another spider-man movie
with sam ramey and toby maguire that'd
be interesting to see
uh slightly off topic but a good
question from key wise are the streams
moving to wednesday for the low-key
watch party 100
they'll be tuesday uh tuesday night yes
yes
yes tuesday and we are pumped for loki
loki is like what i'm most excited for
um
i love him as loki and i love owen
wilson that dude's awesome
owen wilson's hilarious i think he's
gonna play such a good role
yeah gameboy 98 thanks for another super
chat should the ultimate goblin
be in the mcu or the normal suit goblin
normal osborne um i would say normal
because we don't even have
him yet you know like it would be nice
to
to see him for him to show up um which
you know he is rumored
norman osborne green goblin is rumored
to be the main villain
um and i
i hope that's true and i hope we get
stuck with an actual
norman osborne like i hope they don't
just like oh here's another one from one
movie and that's it like i hope
i hope some of the links are true where
it's norman osborne's going to be like a
pretty big character moving forward
so we've gotten some pretty pretty legit
plot leaks
like i would say based off of what i've
heard and stuff like that
yeah do you think osborne is the big bad
or do you think he's a behind-the-scenes
character and this builds him and
there's a different big bad like what do
you think
the spider men are going up against in
this film what are they fighting against
i like i like so okay here's what i
think
i and i think this would be a great way
to
tie it together i think mysterio
in the last movie he lied
about being from another multiverse but
i think his story came from reality
i think the blip did cause a rift in
reality
and i think people are like showing up
and i think that's how this whole thing
gets introduced
right mysterio isn't actually from
another reality but he went with
like what he could go with people are
showing up from different missions
right so he says i'm from a different
reality
to be the hero to say all the stuff blah
blah blah right
i think that would be cool i think it
would tie it really really well um
because well it's not it's not
it's not um nick fury i was gonna say
nick fury said it's not nick fury
but it's talos but you know he when he
was talking about he's like
he's from earth just not another earth
and they talked about the different
universes this earth 616 blah blah blah
he seemed very knowledgeable about that
like like
you know right it wasn't like it wasn't
like nothing right he didn't make it up
it was some very specific details
right and i think i and all the shows
that we're watching right now take place
presumably before spider-man far from
home
right or at least leading right up juan
division certainly does
actually falcon winter soldier does take
place before because far from home is
eight months after
end game so so yeah
you know we we don't know that much yet
no for sure um
so i wonder how much you know so he
worked so on your point about
uh mysterio you know he worked for tony
stark presumably relatively high up
because he had a lot of information
about stark tech and everything you
wonder how much
you know there's a stark division that's
studying this and found out about the
multiverse and
they couldn't break into it because the
technology didn't exist but they knew it
existed and that's where
mysterio got the whole idea about it and
if he's not dead you know
he shows back up and he's like i knew
that this existed i just didn't know we
could access it access it you know yeah
something like that right yeah
yeah maybe uh i hope he's not dead but
marvel has a tendency to like use
big actors for villains and then they're
so they can be one and done
so they don't have to commit to multiple
movies so i fear mysterio might actually
be dead
although i don't think he's done no i
don't think so i just fear that he is
i'd love for him to not be what a great
character uh guam or kwame
again not sure to pronounce it thanks
for another super chat do i think
toby and andrew will stay in the mcu i
don't no
i don't i would like i would like that
but no i don't sadly
uh gameboy 98 thanks again for super
chat there's an image of a black kid
in a mocap suit and one of no way home
shoots could that be mouse yeah
it could um
i was thinking mocaps yeah i was
thinking when i when i hear mocap i
don't know why i think i like the helmet
that the hulk used and i was like
that doesn't mean but then but but uh
tom holland's mocap suit is just
yeah i mean it could be uh it very well
could be
and if miles is introducing this awesome
i just hope he's in the main mcu um
as far as the villains i i think
or i hope that it's like a sinister six
i would love to see a situation because
we have two villains confirmed already
um a lot of others i don't know if they
use craven anymore
yeah because i heard that was big and
then all of a sudden they kind of
pittered out
well if you if you think about like the
stuff that's happening
with sony and disney how they just made
a deal i mean it very well
could have been it's crave a movie
no it's gonna be a multiverse movie
because
avengers end game did this and sony
thinks but if we throw all spider-mans
in one movie we could beat that i
i don't know but i can see how that
would be
a business decision by the studio
and how about how about you answer this
one so
doc ock at the end of spider-man when he
sacrifices himself to save the world
yeah you know you would say he's a good
guy now
i know i was thinking about that too how
does he go into this movie
switching back to being an antagonist
maybe he
so i thought about this and here's my
thoughts and give me one second leonardo
lozano thanks for that super chat what
if they all fight their own main
villains
that would be pretty cool toby finding
doc andrew electro and so on i think
that would actually be pretty cool
pretty that would be like
very cinematic um going back
on this i've actually thought about this
because i thought yes alfred melinda had
a change of heart at the end
and he said i will not die a monster
but he will find himself in a new
universe
parallel universe and
he will have presumably discovered that
time travel is also possible
because they could say like because he
could ask what happened and like to blip
the avengers went back in time blah blah
blah
and could see that as a way to bring his
wife back
and then he says something like that
that's good stop me
there you go i i fought one spider-man
before
basically kicked his butt i'll do it
again yeah i died to save the world
exactly oh i like that
i think i think i think him trying to
bring his wife back and do it
oh that's a huge motivation to do
anything right anything and everything
you need to do even if it's bad you know
he has the tendency there he knows he's
capable of it that would be a really
cool
motivation for him and he doesn't find
access to it and then osborne looks them
up and he's like hey i'll give you this
if you bring me the spiderman
wow i like it i like it i definitely
think osborne should be the person
bringing the sinister six together
like he's finding these okay so let's
let's kind of do this math
yeah let's make a let's get a where's
the yarn we need some right
um okay michael keaton
vulture um scorpion
we'll count shocker shockers in it too
okay uh
and then electro doc
norman osborne sinister six you can even
play shocker with somebody
but scorpion and vulture are already
there during the mcu
main timeline yep then add two more
alfred molina's
jimmy fox electro that's two and then
green goblin green goblin
and then throw craven in there whoever
else in there right
yeah um morbius venom throwball there
right
right yeah yeah i hope and maybe osborne
doesn't even have to be a part of the
sinister six maybe he could just
control them and put them together right
maybe he's not the green goblin
maybe he's just norman osborne right and
there could be others
that are the sinister six and he's just
running it right exactly
exactly all right mysterio comes back
oh yeah right if he's not dead i'd be
all about that i would like mr
you know the good guys have cracked time
travel
right how much longer until the bad guys
do it
i don't think much longer i actually
think some bad is going to come out of
the quantum realm exactly
exactly exactly exactly that leads us
into doctor strange
right exactly joel westberry thanks for
that super chat do you think
this spider-man movie will be in game if
it has all
of the spider-man in it yeah i do i
actually do
i i personally do believe that this one
will i think they're
going all out for this one because the
last one was the first spider-man film
to make over a billion dollars
and i think they see a lot of potential
to kind of cash
in on the mcu
and so what and then you have to think
about like what's going on in the mcu
right now
multiverse breaking blah blah blah
so many questions that people want
answers to so
if i'm sony i'm thinking well clearly
spider-man does better within the mcu
right right we can make the most money
out of this our
our first spider-man movie ever far from
home made a billion dollars
right everyone loves dumb hall and a
spider-man and they're doing this whole
multiverse thing where they're going to
have like more than one
version of people hell let's throw toby
maguire and andrew garfield in and make
this movie freaking crazy
right well then you think about the
implications of the sony verse
stuff going on with disney and how
they're extending their friendly time
yeah yeah that's getting a lot
it's like this is all setting up for the
future of whatever sony and disney are
trying to plan as well
characters bleeding over both sides and
oh it's going to be so cool
yeah there's a lot that can do i saw
some people asking
like in the chat about some other people
like spider-man noir spider-ham
i don't think that stuff's coming in i
think that's strictly
uh into the spider-verse stuff animated
stuff right yeah i think
i mean if i'm sony i i keep it to the
three spider-man
and sinister six right right don't
overdo it the si the sing like tom
holland's peter parker
the 18 year old kid now
probably can't take on the sinister six
alone
right but luckily the multiverse is kind
of tearing open the reality is cracking
and you're going to get some help from
you know two spider-man that everybody
loves
and going back to like our original you
know live stream topic today
andrew garfield is now all over the
place
oh my gosh the dude can't get him like
just just go home dude
you're cute elliot rosser
um yeah he he he's all over the place
now
and it's so weird how he quickly changed
his story
or like got away from i want to say his
scripture yeah we'll call it the slave
the werewolf i'm not the werewolf
i'm not the effing werewolf right i'm
not
the mafia he got away from that so fast
and i think it's so funny because i just
think i almost think he doesn't really
know what to say
and he doesn't want to keep saying the
werewolf so he's kind of like you know
trying to be like impromptu like making
stuff up and that's when he starts
stuttering and stuff
yeah like um like i'm like um like i'm
like i'm like him
yeah he likes them he likes them yeah
uh here's what i will say never say
never and then he says never say never
so he goes from saying i never got the
call i never got the call
in which uh jake hedge pointed out you
know yeah your agent got the call
well here's my big issue with that line
all of these interviews happened
after filming has been completed
right so if it's never say never it's
like well it's too late for never say
never so you either know something
you're not telling us
i don't know it's so many different
reasons why that doesn't make sense
a lot of different reasons why that
doesn't make sense hi guys this is
stormbreaker we're giving it away right
now i'm not sure if you
knew that just follow both of us oh no
it's lit up turned on
and it's gonna stay turned on for like a
really long time now
but it's awesome it's very heavy uh
but it's it's really cool i always gotta
flex it
um i'm sorry rocket oh i didn't have
another question wait hold on hold on
you have something to say
i have super chats
sing morning gentlemen you think
bringing back
oc molina aqualina kind of achievements
his ultimate sacrifice and spider-man 2
they better nail it or there will be
blood um
i don't think it cheapens it if they
give him a really good story like we
mentioned before i don't know if you
just jumped in
but i think if he like goes to a
different universe and he realizes that
time travel is possible and like
multiple realities and stuff and he
thinks that he could bring his wife back
i think that's a good story
i think that's a really good story um
there was one i missed
joe westberry i introduced good actor
the interviews for yeah uh i thought
andrew g
was good actor at the interview support
i'm going to assume you're saying i
thought andrew
was a good actor right yeah like
because it's just nerves right i mean
well it's a big thing to mess up right
yeah
john dunham i have a theory what if
opening title screen they play each
spider-man's theme from each movie dude
how cool would that be
and thanks for that super chat yeah i
hope we get like if it really is you
know all three spider-man which you know
i hope they go all out
i hope they go all out like at this
point in time it's pretty
oh i just feel like
it's re i'm always like i'm so
i'm so hesitant
to to say like yeah let's confirm like
they're in it blah blah blah
because it's not officially confirmed
yet right
but there's so many legitimate
reputable people trade companies
saying yeah they're in it and there's
you know they're still saying like
oh um yeah they're telling them to lay
low and all this stuff like that like it
it just it really does seem like it's
confirmed i'm just gonna
i mean it really does seem like it's it
seems like this is it like this is a
spider-verse film i believe it
um i'm just not gonna press so hard
because i firmly believe mephisto would
be in one division
i firmly believe that and i was very
very wrong
and i found evidence for mephisto to be
in one division which turned out to be
nothing so
yeah you know and and and
marvel's smart oh yeah marvel
is a group of very very talented people
who are good at what they do
and they're aware of their fan base
so what do you think the possibility is
that maybe all of this mephisto stuff
you know because they definitely put
stuff in there oh for sure
so what if they're just trying to
discredit us
so that when we're like guys
spider-man's coming it's like oh yeah
so they're just trying to really just
push us out of the way
yeah right they're smart enough to do
stuff like that
they are and when i
talked to kevin fogg yeah i legitimately
thought he was going to be like
you're the freaking guy
[Laughter]
who started all the stuff
but no um no i think i i
i truly do think this is uh the big
three the spider-verse film that's
that's what i think i
i i do i think if we were searching for
evidence only and there wasn't like a
bunch of reputable trade sources and
people
saying that yeah they're in the movie
then i would be like uh
i mean there's evidence for it but who
knows but we we have these things right
right we have these people we have these
you know media outlets
like deadline all these people like
saying they are going to be in it
and we have the confirmation we have the
confirmation
of jamie foxx and up for molina right
where the heck does that mean and he
told us what director john watts told
him
you know like nobody really does in this
universe nobody really dies
now again if they're not in the movie
what a hard troll
from like everybody from alfred molina
from jamie foxx
you know like that's not on us that's on
you i mean that really is marvel going
out of their way
to make people think it's something that
it's not
which is not going to feed which i think
at this point if if
i'm if i'm marvel and it's not a
spider-verse film i'm sitting there
going like we need to have like a press
conference just be like guys
i know there's a lot of crap going on
they're not in it like
right you know
like if kevin feige gets up on marvel
studios youtube page
live and says guys this is not a
spider-verse film
right i'll believe it i believe it if
you sent tom holland out again to be
like no guys it's not i'm it's just not
gonna work
no no i see some people
asking about the venom two trailer um
daniel richmond or daniel rbcademan
what do you know he goes by the two
different ones uh he's the one that said
that he
he heard it was soon he suspected it to
be in
april what are we in may
uh 10th almost he said that he thought
that it would be in may because they
said soon er they thought it was going
to be in april
because he heard that the trailer was
soon but he wasn't given an official
date so
i mean heck man it could be any day now
for every you know everybody asking
uh clearly marvelous plans they drop
that new trailer and stuff like that and
sony's gonna kind of jump around that
right because this isn't a mcu film
at least that we know um so i would just
uh if i hear anything
uh i'm hesitant to to do updates about
venom 2 right now since
we kind of thought that was a sure thing
and no one really knows right now
but daniel richmond said soon and he's
pretty spot on with
trailers not gonna talk about like his
other
leaks and stuff like that but with
trailers very spot on um
uh what's the more what's the deal with
morbius and
venom 2 connection with the mcu well
we're not really sure right now because
they made a new deal
and it seems like the new deal is going
to be pretty lenient for
the characters to cross over um from
what i know so far right now is they can
connect to
spider-man films only right
so morbius can appear in the mcu if it's
in a spider-man film he can't jump in
armor wars
so that's that's what i'm thinking right
now so
i i personally think um
uh angel arriaga junior do i think loki
is the reason for the spider-man
multiverse
i think loki is gonna gonna open a lot
of stuff
up and it's really going to show us what
the multiverse is i don't think it's the
reason i
i think the snap is the reason
i think that much cosmic energy is the
reason is what i should
right just so much going on yeah yeah um
so yeah i i i think
it's funny how andrew is changing up his
story now
yeah um and it makes me more convinced
that he's in the movie
and
and i'm going to be curious to like
hear the interviews after the movie
where it's like oh we had to keep it a
secret it was so hard and blah blah blah
you know what i mean
i'm curious to see those i'm curious to
see those but uh
but yeah i'm gonna go ahead and say stop
the super chats now guys so i don't want
to miss any we're about to log off here
but
um until i don't know should we move the
should we move the live streams to
tuesday now to get to get
to get people ready for the loki live
streams i mean
yeah we could do that i think we're
gonna live stream on tuesday nights now
guys
just to you know get in line with loki
because loki's gonna be
late tuesday night live stream slash
wednesday morning at
1am 12 30 a.m
yeah so look out for us
tuesday it's only like five days away
now
look out for us tuesday it's gonna be
the next live stream it's probably gonna
be around five six o'clock
um what what are we in
mountain time yeah yeah uh six
or five six o'clock mountain time this
upcoming tuesday
next week the next tuesday so
uh let us know what you think in the
comments are the guys showing up
i think they are and if you want to
enter oh
to win stormbreaker not this one a brand
new one this is mine
my lifestyle breaker not yours if you
want to enter to win stormbreaker just
follow us both on youtube
cosmic wonder cosmic culture go comment
on some videos
that's how we choose so
chris any final thoughts um i'm really
excited to see this
this movie is going to open up a lot of
things i think from all of these shows
we're getting a lot of questions and i
think spider-man is where we start to
get a lot of big answers so i'm excited
i do think andrew is full of it
yeah um like i said if he wasn't among
us i would have voted him out a long
time ago so
he would have been the first person i
voted out so
awesome episode love doing this can't
wait to be back next tuesday uh one day
we'll uh
we'll make a name for this yeah one day
we'll
we'll uh we'll still we'll we'll still
have to do that poll on uh
we're still like thinking like cosmic
corner
i i don't know but uh if you guys have
any thoughts for that put them in the
comments down below you can still
comment after the video was ended
um and we appreciate everybody stopping
by appreciate all the super chats
appreciate all the regular chats
peop appreciate everybody who is just
just sitting there watching man now i'm
stuttering it's like i'm in spider-man
no way home geez
now i'm voting warren out oh no i'm next
i'm taking stormbreaker with me
but all right guys hey thank you to
everybody for showing up we love you
guys this community is awesome
chris say something so i can say woof
woof and it can be the last thing oh
yeah the last word has the big wolf
thanks everybody thank you for joining
go ahead check out cosmic culture good
luck in the giveaway and much love
woof